You know,
I'll do three different hotels in a week cause I'll do like a Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday like with gigs and then by the time Sunday rolls around I'm a mess in
rough shape.
Yeah.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
I mean it's a threat detection thing.
Uh,
I mean if you look at other species,
they can do this much more impressively than we can.
So dolphins or any sort of seed dwelling mammal can actually sleep with half a
brain.
So one half of that brain goes into deep sleep.
The other half is wide awake.
That's how people,
the DMV do it.
Those people that work at the department of motor vehicles,
they're there.
They work half asleep.
You ever meet him?
I haven't.
No.
Just teasing you will a DMV listen and going fuck you man.
Next time you come in and get your license renewed,
there's my next NIH grant,
I think looking at the DMV and sleep.
But yeah,
we essay workers.
Same thing.
Same,
same type of human that I've come across.
Yeah,
them too.
I'm just kidding.
Fuckers.
Relax.
Um,
so when you're in a hotel room,
what is happening that you're half your brain is not really sleeping?
Yeah,
so there's different stages of sleep.
There are two principle types.
One is non rapid eye movement sleep or non rem sleep.
The other is rem sleep,
which is also known as dream sleep and non rapid eye movement.
Sleep is further divided into four separate stages,
um,
which are unimaginatively called stages one through four.
We're a creative bunch is easy to remember that just it is true.
Uh,
but I think it's also a low Iq but it's the deep stages of sleep three and four
of that non rapid eye movement.
That's where a lot of sort of body replenishment takes place,
grief for the cardiovascular system,
metabolism,
all of those good things.
But that's the deep sleep that one half of your brain will resist going into
when you're sleeping in a foreign environment.
So it stays in this kind of lighter stage,
almost like a threat detection system.
And you can imagine why,
you know,
it's an unusual context.
Evolutionarily,
it would make a lot of sense to just have that sort of on guard.
One half of the brain don't make so much sense and that,
that,
that really,
for me,
it fills in the blanks of like why even if I get,
you know,
seven,
eight hours sleep on the road,
I'm still kind of just out of it.
Yeah.
And that's in fact,
probably one of the,
I think the most impressive parts of new research on sleep.
It's not just about quantity,
it's also about quality and quality can be as detrimental if you don't get it as
a reduction in total quality.
I mean,
both are essential,
but I think it speaks exactly to your point.
You just don't feel like it's a refreshing sort of deep sleep.
Um,
yeah,
it feels totally different.
Um,
it just,
it feels like,
I guess I would say it feels like half asleep.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's really kind of out.
It does feel.
Um,
one of the things that I noticed,
I did this thing with my friends called sober October where we,
um,
didn't smoke any pot or Dooney no drinking at all.
Nothing for a month and a when I did it.
One of the things I've found is that after about,
I don't know how many days,
but it was noticeable that I would have these incredibly vivid dreams and then I
had read that marijuana does something to suppress heavy rem sleep.
Like what,
what?
What is happening there?
Yeah,
so both of those chemicals,
both of which are used as a sleep aid,
alcohol and marijuana are actually very good at blocking your dream sleep,
your rapid eye movement,
sleep.
And so what happens is that the brain is quite clever in this regard.
It builds up a clock counter of how much dream sleep you should have had but
have not been getting.
And it starts to develop this increasing appetite and hunger for dream sleep.
So that finally when the alcohol actually gets out of your system sober October,
the liver,
the name,
that's all of a sudden where you get what's called a rem sleep rebound effect,
where you not only get the normal amount of rem sleep that you would normally
have,
you get that plus the brain tries to get back.
Some of that dream sleep that it's been losing over the past,
maybe 11,
11 months.
Um,
so you get this right,
20 years.
I didn't want to make any assumptions.
Uh,
so,
um,
so you get this rem sleep rebounded effect and that's where you have these
really intense dream sleep,
um,
situations.
It's the same reason that people will,
they'll say like,
I had a bit too much to drink last night.
Maybe it was a Friday or Saturday.
They sleep in late and they say,
I just have these crazy dreams.
What happens there is a kind of a,
an acute version where the alcohol is swilling around in your system and after
about six hours,
your liver and your kidneys to finally excrete it,
all of the alcohol and your brain has been deprived of dream sleep for that
first six hours.
So then it feasts in the last couple of hours.
And that's why you have these really bizarre dreams after you've been drinking a
little bit too much.
Oh,
wow.
So what is happening with marijuana though specifically?
Do you know?
Yeah,
so marijuana,
um,
it,
it does help.
People will help it.
It puts people to sleep quicker.
Although I think the question is whether it's really naturalistic sleep or not
that they go into.
Certainly with alcohol it's not that nightcap idea is,
is a misnomer.
Alcohol will actually,
well it's a form of drugs that we call the sedatives and sedation is not sleep.
It's very different,
but we often mistake one for the other.
Marijuana seems to act in a physiologically very different way.
It doesn't target the same receptors in the brain.
So it's unclear whether this speed with which you fall asleep after having a
session with marijuana is actually natural sleep.
Let's assume it is the problem.
However,
is that it?
Then we'll start to disrupt rem sleep.
It will start to block the process.
We think perhaps at the level of the brainstem,
which is where these two types of sleep,
non rem and rem sleep we'll actually get sort of worked out.
That's where marijuana may actually impact dream sleep and shut it down.
Block it.
Have there been any studies on chronic marijuana smokers like those uh,
dawn to dusk type characters that just are constantly high?
Like,
and what happens to their brain from not cause they must never hit rem sleep.
Yeah.
So people haven't looked at marijuana.
They have looked at alcohol though.
Hmm.
Exactly that.
So what happens is if you look at alcoholics,
um,
they will have some thing often when they come off alcohol suddenly called
Delirium tremens which is where the sort of DT there,
what happens is that the alcohol has been blocking dream sleep for so long and
the pressure for dream sleep is built up so powerfully in the brain.
It actually just spills over into wakefulness.
And so the brain just says,
look,
okay,
if I'm not going to get this dream sleep whilst you're asleep,
I'm just going to take it whilst you're awake.
And so you start to essentially dream while you're awake.
It's this sort of collision of two states of consciousness.
So you get delirium.
Wow.
I always thought the dts were detoxing.
Other one,
someone said someone's going through the dts delirium.
Tremor.
Yeah.
Delirium.
Tremens mm.
So what like what is going on with them when this is happening?
So if they are going through this delirium during the day,
while they're conscious,
what's physiologically happening.
So it's almost as though the veil of rem sleep gets pulled over the waking brain
as it were.
So you have this mixed state of consciousness that you can pick up with brain
wave recordings
and he just tells me,
I mean in some ways how necessary sleep must be if that's the lengths that the
brain will go to to get that,
which it's been missing.
Yeah.
Just shows you why,
you know,
it took mother nature 3.6 million years to put this thing called an eight hour
sleep necessity in place.
And we've come along and within the space of a hundred years,
we've lopped off almost 20% of that if you look at the data.
Wow.
Really?
Yeah.
And so many people take pride in that too.
I don't need eight hours sleep.
I got three,
I'm good.
Ready to go kick ass and dominate the world.
Yeah.
It's the sort of like sleep machismo instead of attitude.
There is a lot of that,
right?
Yeah.
Many baby.
I like sleep.
Well,
I mean,
you'd be glad to know that.
Then,
you know,
men who sleep five to six hours a night,
we'll have a level of testosterone,
which is that of someone 10 years their senior.
So a lack of sleep will age.
You buy a decade in terms of that critical aspect of wellness for reality and it
muscle strength testing,
sexual performance.
Incredible.
Wow.